the carbonated water business is surging
as more Americans myself included turn
away from soda and other sugary drinks
sales of Seltzer club soda and sparkling
water are up by double digits they now
total at least 2.2 billion dollars a
year the industry is booming for big
beverage companies and startups alike
bon appetit editor-at-large Andrew
Knowlton shows us how new flavors and
products are raising its status cases of
ramblers sparkling water began rolling
out of a canning plant in Austin Texas
last April it was a brainchild of three
men including James Moody and Dave Mead
who knew nothing about the beverage
business I got into the business because
I was actually hooked on soda
you mean Cola like you were soda diet
soda junkie I was told to wean off of it
and I did but I couldn't do it with flat
water I needed some sort of
entertainment right and sparkling water
was the way that I did it and I started
to notice that a lot of America was kind
of going through this weaning off of
coke at the frigerator level at home
start with smell Moody and Mead launched
Rambler into stiff competition
Texas is topo Chico country a brand so
beloved it was noticed by a company
called coca-cola topo Chico is a
phenomenon outside of Texas though most
people probably haven't heard of topo
Chico but we see opportunities to expand
that in a in a measured and appropriate
way coke already had sparkling water
products including their Dasani and
smart water brands buying topo is more
evidence of just how hot the market is I
think this category is important to the
coca-cola company overall the sparkling
water category has has grown double
digits over the past several years Coca
Cola's sparkling water business was up
19 percent in 2018 industry-wide sales
were up more than 13 percent all this
sparkling water that's on the market is
water as of some sort and then co2
that's added into it to give it those
bubbles but that's pretty much it is
that the water that matters here is that
the packaging is that how you position
yourself in the market
yes all of it we realized when we
started getting into it that these
waters taste completely different
depending on the minerality in them so
the flavor of the water itself starts to
get a little bit like wine which I know
sounds crazy but you can taste the
difference when you really get into it
but can people really tell the
difference from one Seltzer to another
do you like the bubbles in that is that
intense yes in a very unscientific taste
test we conducted at the University of
Texas definitely less bubble we asked
people to sample four different brands
of unflavored sparkling water I like
this one and they were able to pick out
a favorite from among them I would say
this is my favorite number three you
like three number three so sparkling
waters vary in their intensity their
carbonation and their bubble size and
add it into that is the ever-expanding
world of flavored waters you've seen
these all over grocery stores Pepsi just
recently launched bubbly joining
behemoth like Lacroix and if you like
your sparkling water with a little bit
of booze there's those two is there room
for all of these sparkling waters on the
market my short answer is yes right now
no in the long term there will be a
consolidation House Pepsi or coke or any
big big companies come and snooped
around rambler and ask you a question I
haven't called me they called you I'll
check my phone after this but I don't
think they know we exist yeah Andrew
Knowlton is joining us now at the table
here I was I thought I was ahead of the
trend looks like everyone is now
drinking bubbled water but is it as good
for you as flat water it is there's been
I think nutritionists will agree and
there's been some studies done that it
hydrates just as well as flat water I
think the one issue is you can't drink
as much of it because you get more full
or quickly which is a thing that some of
the diet industry I think people drink
sparkling water because it makes you
feel fooling you mean you eat less I
didn't make it clear you don't want to
reveal who won the Taste just because
you know we're all like who won Andrew
yeah I'll tell you afterwards okay
I love the toe Pacheco that's not fan
Etobicoke sir we can take intense
bubbles
I can go right up your nose or texting
bubble gets you right here it's right
there I like the koi thank you thank you
nice to have you here